qu'elles soient rouges jaunes ou encore
orange les stars de la toussaint ce sont
elles les chrysanthèmes flore d'automne
pour décorer les cimetières une
tradition née au lendemain de la
première guerre mondiale pour embellir
les tombes des soldats morts pour la
france et près d'un siècle plus tard les
chrysanthèmes reste numéro un des ventes
même si la tendance évolué ces dernières
années on a quand même de plus en plus
de demandes sur des plantes différence
sur des hellébores sur des choses qui
vont vraiment tenir tout l'hiver par
rapport aux présentes m6 met à faire
froid il n'ya pas être grande retenue
coin notre faux pas de gel mais de plus
en plus et puis beaucoup de compositions
différentes varier la plante quand même
que l'on vend le plus reste de
chrysanthèmes
mais par rapport à il ya quelques années
c'est vrai qu'on vend autre chose avec
la fête des mères la saint valentin et
les dates traditionnelles le week-end de
la toussaint est l'un des plus
importants pour le chiffre d'affaires
des fleuristes qui n'hésite pas à
développer leurs services pour répondre
à toutes les demandes et on a des
clients qui viennent spécifiquement pour
des chrysanthèmes et aussi pour les
tombes ont fait beaucoup de livraisons
dans les cimetières
donc on a beaucoup de personnes six de
province qui nous appellent pour qu'on
puisse les bressolais les tombes
donc il y a quand même une activité mais
les différentes aussi bien en magasin
quand livraison chaque année en france
20 millions de pots de chrysanthèmes
sont fondues à la toussaint un marché
qui ne devrait pas connaître la crise de
sitôt